Welcome to the
Data Science Hangout.
Hope everybody's
having a great week.
I'm Rachael, if we
haven't met yet.
Let us know if it's your
first time joining in the chat
so we can all welcome you in.
This is our open space to chat
about data science leadership,
questions you're
facing, and getting
to hear about what's going
on in the world of data
across different industries.
Every week we feature a
different data science leader
as my co-host here to help
lead our discussion and answer
questions from you all.
And together we're all
dedicated to making
this a welcoming
environment for everybody.
So we love to hear
from everyone,
no matter your level of
experience or background
or area of work.
It is totally OK
to just listen in.
There's always three ways you
can ask questions to and also
provide your own perspective.
So, one, you can always jump in
by raising your hand on Zoom.
Two, you could put questions
into the Zoom Chat.
I know you've all heard me
say this a lot of times now.
But feel free to
put a little star
next to your question
in the Zoom chat
if you want me to read
it out loud if you're
in a coffee shop or something,
or if your dog's barking.
But we also have a Slido link
where you can ask questions
anonymously.
And I think our team just shared
that in the chat right now.
We'll reshare it
after for people
who have joined after the
first few minutes, too.
We do share the recordings of
each session up to the Posit
YouTube.
So you can always go
back and rewatch or share
with a friend or coworker.
If you hear anything
loud in the background,
there's some snow falling
off the side of the building
right now.
Hopefully you won't
hear that too much.
But thank you so
much for joining us.
As the co-host today, Dara is a
data science manager at Stripe.
And I'd love to have you
introduce yourself, maybe
share a little bit
about your role,
and also something you
like to do outside of work.
Sure.
So thank you for the intro.
My name's Dara.
As Rachael said, I'm a data
science manager at Stripe
currently.
I've been at Stripe for
about five years now.
My current role
is leading a team
around finance and
operations data science.
So we are very into forecasting.
We do a lot of work on
hierarchical forecasting,
financial forecasting at Stripe,
spend a lot of effort there.
We think a lot about metrics
and overall company metrics
and analytics and how we
can understand our business
performance.
And then we work in the
operations space as well.
So we are working on some
various machine learning
projects there, as well
as capacity planning
and forecasting
on that side too.
So happy to talk about any
of that work in more detail.
Let's see.
One thing I like to
do outside of work--
I used to be kind of
an endurance sports
person, long-distance
triathlons and running.
But I now have a
15-month-old daughter,
who keeps me pretty busy
and spend most of my time
just parenting.
Well, thank you so
much for joining us.
As we kind of wait for questions
to come in from everybody
in the audience
here, I'm curious
if you could kind of give us
a little insight into some
of the problems
that your team is
trying to help solve or
things that you're working on
so you can put us in
your frame of reference.
Cool.
Yeah, let me talk about
a couple of things.
So at Stripe, we're
interested in forecasting,
as many businesses are, in
understanding how much payment
volume are we going
to have next year,
how many active users will we
have, what will our uptime be.
There's a number of
forecasting problems
that come into play that
are a business advantage.
If we are good at them,
we can set the budget.
We can set our targets.
We can direct our
efforts appropriately.
And so my team
spends a lot of time
thinking about
how we can produce
the best forecast for Stripe.
As a side note, I like
forecasting as a data science
area because it's not
one that you always
learn about in a
machine learning course
or spend a lot of time
thinking about in your more
formal education.
I didn't, at least.
But now, on the
business side, it's
an extremely practical business
problem to be able to solve.
But at the same time, it's
very interesting statistically,
and there's a lot
of work that we
do to experiment
and find the best
methods for doing forecasting.
So we do what's called
hierarchical forecasting.
So this means that we want
to have a forecast for Stripe
overall.
We want to know what's our
total payment volume going
to be for the whole company.
But we also want
to know, what is it
going to be for each region?
What is it going to be
for each business type?
What's it going to
be for each cohort?
There's all these
dimensions that flow down.
So you can kind of think of
this as a hierarchy, where
all of the dimensions then need
to add up to the total, right?
We have to have a
coherent hierarchy
is how we talk about it.
And so we use this method
where we can actually
choose any forecasting
method we want
for each node of the hierarchy.
We use a lot of classical
forecasting methods,
like ARIMA and
exponential smoothing.
We also experiment with
other types of methods.
And we use those
to make estimates.
And then we apply sort of
a meta model on top of it,
hierarchical reconciliation, to
basically tweak each forecast
as little as possible
so that they all still
add up to the total forecast.
And that, then, we apply
some additional adjustments
on top of that.
And that becomes the
budget for the company.
Thank you.
I see Mark had a follow-up
question on that.
Mark, do you want to
jump in and ask that?
Yeah.
Sure.
Let me turn my video on.
Just curious about your--
and you kind of went
into the detail there.
But curious about if you're able
to expand on the target setting
methodology and if
you dip into any,
I guess, nonfinancial
targets and, I
guess, different level setting.
I actually literally
have it open
right now working on R,
next fiscal year's targets
for the hospital
system I work for.
So, yeah, just really curious
to get your perspective
on some of the
nonfinancial metrics
that you guys keep track
of and if and how you
do [INAUDIBLE] for those.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah, we do.
We're actually
building a platform
to do general hierarchical
forecasting for any metric
at Stripe.
So we've expanded this.
We do some sales
planning right now,
which is a little bit financial.
We do it for our active users.
And we're looking at
things like uptime,
as well, like how much should
we expect Stripe to be live?
And, yeah, so we generally
find that the approach is-- oh,
and we also do a lot in ops
too, so capacity planning
for our support volume
support tickets.
We found that the
methods are pretty
similar across all of these
different types of problems.
There's a lot of nuance
in terms of making sure
that you capture the data
correctly and actually solve
the business problem, right?
You can just sort of throw
general forecasting methods
at something.
But we have found, in general,
that the hierarchical format
works really well in a business
setting, in that you often
care about some more
detailed dimensions,
and then you also care about
adding up to the whole.
Mm-hmm.
Awesome.
Thank you.
Crystal, I see you asked
a question in the chat too.
Do you want to jump in?
And maybe I missed--
I can ask that one too.
And if you want to add
it in context, feel free.
But the question was, any
exploration of ChatGPT
to identify any possible
or meaningful use?
It's funny you ask.
Yes, we are playing with it.
We actually were playing
with it before it was cool,
I have to say, so back
when it was just GPT3,
before some of the
hype this fall.
We are experimenting with
it in our support flow,
so to be able to help
agents answer questions
more accurately and much
more quickly for our users.
So we are still early days,
but we're pretty enthusiastic.
We've done a lot of NLP work
generally on the op side.
So we classify our
issues using BERT,
which is sort of a previous
generation natural language
processing model.
And that allows us to know
what kind of questions
are getting asked and what
topics our support issues are
about, which we
then use to direct
a lot of internal efforts,
like where should we be making
updates or bug
fixes in our product
based on what the support
tickets are about.
Thank you.
I want to make sure
I get over to some
of the anonymous questions too.
And just remind people,
if you want to use Slido,
you can use that
link in the chat.
But somebody had asked
earlier, I would love to learn,
Dara, how you have
found the transition
from computational immunology
to finance and operations?
Yeah.
I'll try to not blather on
for too long about this.
A lot of the data scientists
have interesting or unusual
career paths.
I'm no exception here.
So I did my PhD in
computational immunology.
It actually started out as
a PhD in pure immunology.
So I was a wet lab biologist,
pipetting and doing
experiments.
I realized pretty
quickly in my PhD--
I took an R class
and a Python class.
And then I took more CS courses.
And I took more statistics
and machine learning
and realized pretty quickly
that was a direction that
would enable me to be a
better biologist and also just
an area of lot of
interest for me.
I was lucky enough to be able
to do a ton of coursework
and really direct my
research that direction.
So by the time I
finished my PhD,
I was doing fully
computational work.
When I finished up, I thought,
what do I want to do next?
I really enjoyed academia.
I had a great time there.
I thought very seriously
about academic postdocs.
And then also thought,
I really like this data
side of what I've been doing.
I really like the statistics
and ML and all the programming
that I've been doing.
And so I looked at data
science positions as well.
So I applied to both.
And in the end, I decided to
take a data science position
because I felt like it was
much more different than what
I had done before and
that I would learn more
in that position just because
it would really force me
to continue to build the skills
that I had started to develop
in my PhD and put me into an
entirely new problem space
that I hadn't been before.
So that's what I did.
I went first to a small
health insurance startup
called Collective Health.
I was there for two years.
The great thing about
going to a startup
is you learn a lot
of data engineering.
And so I spent a lot of time
building pipelines and really
getting to know--
bolstering how you
actually write code
in an environment
with other people
when your PhD is very much just
sort of you and your notebook.
And this was now actually having
to write in a more production
environment.
So I learned a lot there.
And I did health
insurance thinking
that it would be
somewhat related
to my PhD work, which was on
HIV and the immune system.
It turns out not really that
much overlap between those two
subject areas.
But I really love the data
science side of things.
And I really loved
having impact in business
and being able to see
the results of my work
more directly.
So after a couple of years I
decided to move over to Stripe.
Stripe was very appealing
because it was still--
it was big enough
to have invested
in data infrastructure.
There was a ton
of data available.
I was going to be able to do
more statistical and ML-type
work.
But it was still small
enough that there
were a lot of unsolved
problems, which
is actually, five years later,
still true of Stripe today.
And so that's what
made me decide
to do-- that I was more
interested in the data problems
rather than focus on
a particular domain.
It has turned out that financial
payments are a complex system
just like the immune
system is a complex system.
So even though I do not use my
domain knowledge from my PhD
that much, I still use a lot
of the skills that I learned.
I still use a lot of the how
to present, how to do research,
how to think about problems, how
to break down complex problems
all the time.
And so really have
found that if you
think about it the right way,
skills are pretty transferable.
Absolutely.
I'm starting to see a bunch of
other questions coming in too.
And Alan, I saw you
had asked one earlier.
Do you want to jump in/
Sure.
Hi, Dara.
I'm really interested in
part of the forecasting where
if you have to reconcile some
SNE input from people who
historically would have
been setting targets,
like salespeople
and their leaders.
And I don't know what
the organization is,
how it sort of maps to that.
But what's the process
of buy in from them
that the forecasting
you're doing
seems like a realistic
enough picture of the world
that they buy it and that
they'll go work along it?
Or if their input gets
incorporated earlier
in the process
somewhere so they're
brought along kind of from
the beginning in a way,
just curious how
that kind of gets
negotiated out in
the organization.
Super interesting question.
Yeah, and it's ongoing evolution
for how we do this interaction
because it's very
important to get the input
from stakeholders, right?
There might be a big sales
deal coming down the pipeline
that no statistical model
will know about. right?
There might be
some product launch
plans that we're
just not going to be
able to learn from history.
And so we find that
interaction very important.
And when we started
doing this, too, when we
started doing the--
we call it the
statistical forecasting
and the adjustments--
it was all done in
spreadsheets by finance folks.
And we did we
really have to prove
our value of how does a
statistical model actually
help?
So our current system is we
have the statistical model.
We actually do-- that's
all done by data science.
We do backtesting and reports
to be able to build confidence
in each level of the hierarchy
so that people can understand
where do they expect
accuracy, where
do they expect less accuracy.
And then we have a whole process
with the finance and strategy
team, where they make
adjustments to the forecast
and are pretty clear about
where they are doing adjustments
and how it's
affecting the total.
And then we track both, the
statistical versus the adjusted
forecast.
And what we've
learned over time is
that making adjustments in
certain ways or certain places
is very important
and very effective.
And we sort of encouraged
the finance and strategy team
to focus their efforts there.
Whereas in other places,
the statistical model
is quite accurate, and it's
best to spend effort elsewhere.
So that's the baseline of
how we think about it--
again, ever evolving.
But we also have an
embedded model, right?
So we sit with
finance and strategy.
We work really
closely with them.
We really understand
their problems.
It's very much a
partnership-type model
rather than a "throw a model
over the wall" type model.
Great.
That's great.
DARA STRAUSSMAN: Did
that answer the question?
Yeah, it does.
It's really-- and it
sounds like for having
been sort of driving it for
a relatively small handful
of years, it sounds
really mature and really
comprehensive in a
bunch of ways that I
think are really impressive.
So yeah, it's cool.
Thank you.
We still have a lot more
that we would like to do.
Oh, for sure, yeah.
[INAUDIBLE] adjustments.
There's a whole literature about
adjustments and the best way
to do them.
And we applied some
of those things.
But there's so much
more that I think
we could do to really
maximize our effort.
Yeah.
Thank you.
I know you just said you sit
with the finance and strategy
team.
So I was curious, is there
a general data science
team for the whole company, or
is there data science pockets
within each group?
Yeah.
So GENERAL Data
science team-- and I'm
using sit with--
to be clear, I'm
using sit with someone
figuratively here.
We used to sit with them
when we were fully in office.
And now it's sit
with them on Zoom.
But centralized
data science team--
So we have a hybrid
embedded model.
So every data scientist
has a partner team
that they work
really closely with.
So I'm on the business side,
with the finance and operations
teams.
Others might work with
product or engineering teams.
And we really act like
members of that team,
get to know their
problems, get to attend
their meetings, their
offsites, understand
what's going on with them, and
do joint planning together.
And so we'd like to think
it's best of both worlds,
making sure we are solving
real business problems.
But the centralized
data science team
keeps us pushing the
envelope technologically and
innovatively as well.
Yeah, that's really cool.
Deepsha, I see you had a
question over on Slido.
Do you want to ask that here?
Sure.
I withdrew it because Alan's
question was slightly similar.
But I'll ask a
slightly different way.
So you do get finance
and stakeholder buy in.
But sometimes when
you just recently
have started statistical
finance models, what
happens if it deflates
what the previous finance
predictions were?
And have you had
such a scenario?
Because those finds
are so difficult.
And I have said
scenarios as well.
So how do you get
a buy in there?
Yeah.
It's a great question.
As much as you can
bring in confidence
intervals or backtesting
statistics and show here's
what we expect,
those, of course,
are only as good
as your input data.
And that can be challenging
when you're first starting out.
But that is-- finance folks
are very quantitative, right?
They're very data oriented.
They want to know how.
At least our finance books are.
So that helps.
In our experience, it did take
some time just to build trust.
And so it was making sure that
we had all the very detailed
tracking in place.
And so it wasn't
saying, hey, we're
going to replace your model.
It was saying, let's run
them in parallel, right?
And let's just track the
statistical model, the finance
model, maybe some
combination of them
if we want to do
an adjusted model.
And let's look for six months
at how those go and see.
Let's just sort of be
objective about it, if we can.
And that ultimately
was very helpful for us
in building some
trust and confidence.
But it is a relationship.
It does take some time to build.
Definitely.
Thanks, Dara.
Thank you all for all
the great questions too.
I see one on Slido was,
with your forecasting,
how do you share results to
those who make decisions?
Is it through Excel, PowerPoint?
Do you ever use Shiny
or SharePoint, Power BI?
I would love it
if we had Shiny.
We don't have it
set up at Stripe.
So we have our own internal
role forecasting-- sorry, not
forecasting, dashboarding
tool that is SQL based
and allows us to build
pretty nice dashboards
that way on our data.
So we use a lot of that.
We will sometimes make
sort of bespoke plots
in our R or Python
and share those.
We do a lot of PowerPoint or
Google Slides presentations
as well.
And sometimes when we're
working directly with
there certainly are sort of
queries and spreadsheets.
And we try to speak their
language where we can.
So while we might operate
in more of a SQL land,
they might be operating
more of a spreadsheet land.
And so we try to interface
between those things.
Great.
Thank you.
And Abigail, I love your
question in the chat.
I know we get to hear a lot
of different perspectives
on this one.
And I'd love to have
you ask that here.
Oh.
I don't know if we
can hear you yet.
So I can ask it.
And feel free to jump
in after if you want.
But the question
was, how do you feel
about being a manager
versus being in a purely SME
individual contributor role?
Do you still get to code?
These days not as much.
I started as an IC at stripe.
And I transitioned about
a year into my tenure.
And when I first transitioned,
managing a small team,
I still did about 50% coding.
And now I manage usually
between 8 to 10 folks.
So I do more pure
management stuff.
I think I've really
enjoyed the transition.
I find that I think
the key question
to ask yourself if
you're thinking about IC
versus management
is, how motivated you
will be by enabling other folks
to do work versus how motivated
are you by solving problems
and shipping work yourself?
And most people
would be motivated
by both of those things.
But it's really sort
of trying to figure out
for yourself where you want to
prioritize spending your time
and how helpful
each of those roles
might be to you in
achieving that goal.
That's my short answer.
I'm happy to go on more.
These are great questions.
Thank you.
Eugene, I see you had
a question in the chat.
Do you to jump in next?
EUGENE GEIS: Sure.
My question is just about the
sophistication of modeling.
So you seem to discuss quite a
few rather sophisticated models
in your forecasting as you
gave your short summary of what
you're using.
I'm just curious,
has the increase in--
I assume you started
simple, right?
So has the increase
in sophistication
actually significantly changed
your results or your outcomes
as the models have evolved?
Yeah.
This is-- this is
a good question.
So our forecast, I
think the way that we
do the hierarchical
reconciliation
is very important.
And that has certainly increased
in sophistication over time.
Underlying models
themselves, we actually
don't use anything--
most of the time,
they're not super fancy
forecasting models.
We're not doing some
of the things that
are winning the M5 forecasting
competition these days.
It's sort of bread
and butter ARIMA
and exponential smoothing
for the most part.
We'll play with
other models too.
And we have found that for our
particular business problem,
that works really
well because we have
a decent amount of history.
We have-- very important
to capture seasonality.
We're doing monthly forecasts.
So we are able to capture what
we need to capture for those
So the choice of
forecasting model
is so dependent on the problem
that you have and the--
there are so many things to
consider about your input data.
I think if we had a lot
of external aggressors
that we were trying to model
a lot of parallel processes
happening, then,
probably, different kinds
of models, potentially
more of the deep learning
forecasting models that
have come into play
recently might be really
helpful to us as well.
But for the most part, a lot
of bread-and-butter forecasting
models work well for us.
Thank you.
And Trevor, I know you had
a somewhat similar question.
So I just wanted to see if that
addressed your question too,
or if you want to
add on to that.
TREVOR: Yeah.
Hi Rachael.
RACHAEL DEMPSEY: M Hi, Trevor.
TREVOR: It is indeed a
connected question because--
so most forecasting models
look at historical data
to predict the future, right?
So that is assuming that the
past is the future, right?
And of course, we all understand
that can change, right?
So for example, when
COVID came along,
it disrupted many models, right?
Nobody could have
forecasted that COVID
would have had the effect that
it had on businesses, right?
So I'm just wondering to what
extent, Dara, there are factors
that would not have
been in your models that
would have affected maybe
the accuracy of your models?
That's one.
And, two, we use historical
data to make predictions.
At the end of the day--
let's say your
forecasting sales, right?
And you have forecast it to
be a certain amount based
on historical data.
But then when reality happens,
at the end of a period
you get the actual numbers.
So I want to know
two things really.
How close are you
typically to your forecast?
And how do you manage factors
that weren't considered
in the model in the first
place because of you
weren't thinking about those?
I hope I'm clear.
Yeah.
Some fundamental
problems of forecasting
in a business setting.
We do include external
aggressors and--
now.
Of course, we didn't
predict COVID.
When I look back
now, forecasting
was so easy pre-COVID.
And now, post-COVID, it's a
whole different ball game.
So now we do include
aggressors that
try to account for the past
COVID changes in our data.
What we don't want is
to continue forecasting
more COVIDs in the future.
So we do have some
sort of external things
that we use that help
us to predict that.
We also do factor in
macroeconomic variables
on top of our statistical
forecasts that--
again, you still have to
make your own predictions
and sort of decide as a company
what you think might happen.
We do sometimes do
scenario-based planning
as well, baseline,
and here's sort
of the upside or the
downside scenario
to try to give the business
some framework for how
to think about possibilities.
Accuracy and what do we do
in the forecast is off--
so with the
hierarchical forecast,
the general pattern
is that we are not
that accurate at the lowest
levels of the hierarchy,
generally.
If we're forecasting one cohort,
one region, one business type,
that gets to be a pretty
small set of data.
We don't have as much
history, or there
may be erratic
patterns in it, and so
we don't have as much
accuracy down there.
But then when you
add up to the total,
you have a much more
robust data set.
And we tend to be more
accurate at the higher
levels of the forecast.
We do a lot of tracking.
We create a lot of dashboards.
We try to be really clear
with where we're doing well
and where we're not.
We do reforecast
throughout the year
to be able to update our
best guess on where we think
we're going to land,
given more data has
come in throughout the year.
So that is helpful.
And then we just sit side by
side with finance and strategy
and do the analysis
and try to understand
when the forecast was off?
What are the segments
in which it was off?
Can we identify the
root cause for that?
And how can we improve
our forecast model
for the next iteration?
So no magic bullet, certainly.
But a lot of continual efforts
to try to improve over time.
TREVOR: Thank you.
Thank you very much.
And I meant to say
this earlier, too,
I know that I get
to know everybody
when I see people every week.
But when you ask
your question, feel
free to introduce yourself.
Again, I know maybe we
haven't done introductions
in a long time too.
So feel free to throw that in
there, as well, if you want.
You don't have to.
But Nico, I saw you had
asked a question in the chat
a bit earlier.
Do you want to
ask that one next?
Yeah, sure.
Thank you very much.
So I'm going with the
introduction first.
I work in a small data
science team, JP Morgan.
I was interested--
you mentioned--
Dara, thank you so
much for being here.
You talk about that you did
before some kind of analysis
on tickets, on incidents.
I would like to know if you
can mention some of the maybe
key metrics that you track.
And if so, if you also do some
kind of statistical process
control for those.
You're said support tickets?
Is that what you're
asking about or--
yep.
Yeah, so we do the forecasting
for the support tickets.
And we also do some ML modeling
around improving our support
processes.
So I talked about our
issue classification model.
We're working with GPT now too.
Some of the things we track--
total number of
tickets, how long
does it take to solve
a ticket on average,
what is our overall--
how many tickets do
we get to within SLA.
Whatever we set that at.
We are very focused
on user experience.
So we track CSAT, customer
CSAT and what are we
hearing from users in terms
of their overall satisfaction.
We look a lot to
at which tickets--
by some metrics
that we have, which
tickets do we think we did
really great on user experience
and which ones do we think
we did really terribly,
and try to expand
the first bucket
and shrink the second one.
So there's a lot more to it.
But those are some of the
things that we think about.
We don't exactly do
process controls.
We do help with
capacity planning.
So with our forecasts, we feed
into how much vendor capacity
we need to order.
We have a global
network of vendors that
answer our support tickets.
So we work with them too.
But I think there's
actually a lot more room
for even more data
science work there.
Awesome.
Thanks.
Thank you.
Adrian, I think you had a
question a little bit earlier
we didn't get to yet too.
Do you want to jump next?
Yeah.
Hey, thanks.
I'm an analytics
manager here at Wayfair.
I asked a question earlier,
and it might be a little bit
untimely now.
But I'll go back.
You were talking
about the forecasting.
And specifically
you were talking
about how you integrated--
or you allowed it
to be influenced
by the SMEs near the
end of the process.
And I'm curious--
or actually straight
up adjusted by SMEs at
the end of the process.
I'm curious how
much frontloading
that SME adjustment might take
place, like financial growth
projections or marketing
budgets, things like this?
How much of that actually
takes place at the beginning?
And how much of that initial
forecasting is really
just if the past repeats itself,
here's what would happen.
And if there's not
a perfect answer,
because you said there is a
data science team sort of does
that piece, maybe do you have
a favorite infrastructure
or framework or resource to
see how these get navigated?
So the question is about how
much does the finance team make
their own projections
that they might
add to our forecast
versus how much is it
sort of after the fact, once
the forecast is in place?
Yeah.
Yeah, exactly.
I've seen both of
these sort of cases
happen, where finance
has a 33% growth.
And that's where we're going.
So you really
better track on that
because it's sort of a
self-fulfilling prophecy.
But I've also seen it where
we start with a vacuum.
And I'm curious what
your experience has been.
I'm curious if there's
a best way [INAUDIBLE]??
Gotcha.
Yeah.
So I think our
approach has typically
been to divide the
forecast into segments.
So there are-- I
alluded to this earlier.
There are places where the
statistical models do really
well.
We have enough history.
There's not a lot of external
factors that influence that.
It's sort of a
continuous time series
that we can forecast
pretty well.
And so we sort of explain that
to the finance and strategy
team and work with them and
show them the statistics on it.
And then we find that there
are other places where
that kind of financial
modeling is very fruitful
and is very helpful to adjusting
the forecast, where there are
things that the statistical
model will do less well
or might not know
about or really could
use some adjustment.
And that's how, in
those places, we really
open it up and
encourage adjustments.
I actually think we could have
even more process control.
We were just talking
about controls around this
and around how we do
the adjustment process.
That's something I'd like
us to continue to work on.
But that's generally
how it works.
So the finance team does
do some modeling and does
have their sort of
priors, if you will,
that they're adjusting
the forecast by.
But we work together
to make sure
that they are spending their
effort in the right ways when
they do this.
Thank you.
Yu, I'm sorry I didn't notice
your hand on Zoom before.
Do you want to jump in?
Sure.
Hi, Dara.
Yu Cao here.
So first, thank
you for your time,
and thank you for all the
insights you've shared.
Similar background here.
I'm a data science professional
working in a finance company.
And before that, you worked
in computational immunology.
And for me, I worked
in biochemistry.
So I'm a similar pathway here.
So I have one question.
So because we both know
that for forecasting models
in the finance field,
one of the challenges
is to incorporate
macroeconomic factors,
such as GDP, unemployment rate,
inflation, all these things.
So I'm wondering for
all the forecasting
models you mentioned,
do either of them
use macroeconomic variables?
And if it does,
what do you think
is the best practice to
incorporate such variables?
Yep, good question.
Yep.
This is very important to us
and with 2022, for example,
became even more
important for us
to understand the effect of the
macro economy on our forecast.
So we do.
We currently have this as sort
of a second layer of modeling
that's sort of an
overlay that we
put on our statistical
model, where we say--
we do our best to learn as
much as we can from the past
about how things like GDP
might affect our forecast
and apply those as a
secondary model to our model.
One thing that's
worked really well
is having scenarios here
because we can make our best
predictions, but
in the end, it's
still predictions with these
macroeconomic factors, right?
It's not as if
incorporating them magically
makes your forecast work.
You still have to
decide what the future's
going to look like.
And so having different
scenarios, high, medium, low,
or however we set it
up different ways,
different cycles, to give the
business some indication of,
we can't predict
the future either.
We don't know what's going to
happen with the macro economy.
But this at least
allows them to say, OK,
if something goes well, here's
what we might expect to happen.
If we want to plan to a
sort of worst-case scenario,
here's how we might do that.
And you can imagine
different sort
of business
decision-making scenarios
they might want to
use different ones.
Thank you.
And Marlene, I see
your hand's raised too.
[INAUDIBLE]
RACHAEL DEMPSEY: There you go.
We can hear you.
Yeah.
So hi.
Long time caller,
first time listener.
No, I'm just kidding.
Dara, thanks for
presenting this morning.
Sorry.
The coffee's just
kicked in, gang.
So I'm all over the place.
I've shared on
numerous calls before
that I'm just kind of an
army of one in my company.
We don't have a formal
data science team.
We're far from the machine
learning area of tech.
And right now my
focus is just building
a culture that understands that
there's a need for data science
and giving some practical
uses for automation
and better analytics.
So my question to you is--
it's more around mentorship.
I wanted to know if you guys
had any kind of culture that
promotes, say, mentorship?
Do you, say, have a
senior data scientist
that takes a junior under their
wing, or even a fledgling data
scientist, just somebody who's
got some great analytic prowess
that somehow gets-- they'll
coming into the fold?
I don't know.
Take that question
where you want to go.
But it's around
mentorship, essentially.
Thanks, Dara.
Totally, yeah.
Thank you for asking.
We do have a mentorship program.
So we have-- there is
one within data science.
Our team is-- what
are we around--
170, 180 folks right now.
So we've gotten
big enough that we
do have a spectrum of more
junior to more senior data
scientists.
We do pair them up and allow
them to exchange knowledge
and mentorship.
More formally, we have--
some years we have an
intern program, as well,
where we've taken in folks
who are sort of finishing up
some level of schooling and
had them as summer interns
on data science.
A lot of them have
converted then
to full-time data scientists,
and that has worked out really
well for us.
We also have a very
strong learning culture
on our data science team.
And so we-- part of having a
centralized data science team
brings this benefit.
So we do a lot of
lunch and learns,
where we teach each other
about our current work.
We have a learning group,
where we will read a blog post.
Or at some points,
we've actually
gone through a whole
Coursera course together.
Or depending on the
interests of the group,
we'll sort of work
together on those.
And then we have various sort
of targeted seminars at Stripe,
too, as well.
So there's the ML seminar.
There's a more
general tech seminar.
Sometimes we'll bring in
external speakers as well.
So I think that can be--
that's probably not
unique to Stripe.
I think that's something
that data science brings
to a company really well is most
data scientists are motivated
by continual
learning, continuing
to expand your skills, getting
to try out new methods,
getting to just continue
to both add both depth
and breadth to your
technical skill set.
So, yeah, I found that to be a
really positive part of working
as part of a data science team.
And I see Adrian
had a follow up there
on which Coursera course
did the team do together?
This was, like, two
or three years ago.
We did the deep learning course.
At the time, there was just,
I think, one general deep
learning course.
It probably has expanded now.
Nice.
And kind of, I guess, follow-up
question too Marlene's,
too, I was poking
around on LinkedIn
and saw a few roles at Stripe.
And I noticed that
one of them mentioned
helping to build the data
science community there.
And so aside from
some of the learning
and getting together
to learn together,
are there other ways that
people highlight their work,
like internal meetup
groups or things like that
or Slack or Teams channels?
Yeah.
We have-- so we have a very
big written culture at Stripe.
And that includes emails.
And so we send what we call
shipped emails company wide.
So you finish a project.
You're encouraged to write
it up and send it to--
if it's a very big project, you
send it to the whole company.
If it's sort of a
medium-sized project,
we might send it to the data
science team and our partner
teams.
But strong culture of shipping
and celebrating work that way,
as well as making
sure that your work
has as much impact as possible.
Sometimes sharing it with
another team or another person
actually helps you find
another use case for something
that you've built. So strong
culture of sharing there.
We have various levels
of team meetings as well.
So whole data
science team meeting
where we do sort of lightning
talks, a few short talks.
And so that's a big
group about recent work.
And then we have our
medium meeting, where--
medium meeting, like,
maybe 30 or 40 people,
where we give maybe a
15-minute presentation
on more polished work.
And then in my team
meeting of 10 people,
we do very early stage
technical feedback.
And so for that one, we
require that you do not
prepare anything for it
and just put up your code,
put up your doc, put up your
random notes on something,
and talk through
something very early stage
that you're thinking about.
And we found that
one, in particular,
to be really helpful
to folks, this sort
of low-stakes environment where
you can bounce your ideas off
of each other.
Especially in
COVID times, that's
been really helpful to
building some team camaraderie
and also sharing good feedback.
Alan, I see you just
put something in the chat.
You want to jump in next?
Sure.
I'm thinking of lots
of questions today.
I'm curious, Dara, if you have
a balance that you can maintain
between the sort
of routine things
like financial
forecasting that has
an annual cadence or a quarterly
requirement or whatever
with room to experiment
and learn new methods,
try out tools, shop those
around into the organization?
And how do you meet all
those needed commitments
with-- how do you balance
that with room to explore,
room to grow for your team
to make sure that they're
able to try things out that
may not have a known business
connection yet, but
you want to give them
that kind of opportunity?
Is that something
you're able to do?
And if so, how do you do it?
Yeah, million-dollar question.
So we do a few strategies here.
This also is something
that we continually
work on and try to promote.
We do planning each
half with our partners.
And so we aim to
get-- and when we
do this sort of
biannual planning,
we aim to get the most important
projects to them on our roadmap
so that we can jointly
decide what those are.
And that allows--
typically, there
within those larger
projects, there's
some room for new methods or
innovation, experimentation,
while still working
towards something
that is key to the business
and that partners have decided
is important to them.
And so that works
well for trying
to build in a bit more of that
sort of longer-term project
that allows the data scientists
to dig in on the methodology
side.
But then, of course, we build
flexibility into the process
too.
Things come up.
There may be urgent things--
there are all the time-- that
come up that are very important
as well that folks work on.
And so we just sort of
continually evaluate those.
And I spend a ton of time
just having conversations
about resourcing
and making tradeoffs
on what the team is working on.
I see that as a key
role of a manager.
We also do-- we have a good
tradition of quarterly career
chats.
So I do quarterly
chats with everyone
on my team, talk about their--
chance to zoom out
and talk longer term
about their interests.
And from there I find
out what kind of projects
are they interested in that
they're not currently working
Or are there things they're
working on that they're
less interested in?
You have to find the
business needs, right?
We're not a research team.
We don't do sort
of pure R&amp;D work.
But often by just
having a good grasp
on where people want
to go and what they're
interested in-- when I
hear about new projects,
I'm able to help target
those appropriately to folks.
Awesome.
Thanks.
A lot of that sounds
familiar, stuff that I'm
trying to do better as well.
Yeah.
It's a continual
process, for sure.
ALAN SCHUSSMAN: Uh-huh.
Yeah.
I was just making a note of
the quarterly career charts
too.
And I was just curious
how do you frame
that with your direct reports?
Is that an actual
formal process that they
go through or just
informal conversation?
So the first time when I have
a new direct report, either
new to Stripe or new to
reporting to me, I ask them--
it's a fairly-- a
more structured chat.
We go through their
career history
and ask a lot of questions
about the decisions
that they've made along
their way and their interests
and what brought them
to Stripe and a lot
of just getting to understand
their career motivations.
For subsequent ones,
it is more open.
A lot of folks have a
more structured idea
of what they want
from their career.
And we might talk through
that plan each time.
I'll often come with
questions or new frameworks
that I'm thinking about for
how to think about your career
and bring those.
Some folks are either earlier
or more open or less sure
about their career.
And in that case, I might direct
the conversation a little bit
more.
So it's fairly tailored
to the individual.
Thank you.
So I see two anonymous
questions that
are kind of on the same topic.
So let me combine
them both here.
But the questions are around,
do you support both R and Python
users on your team?
And what does that
split look like?
Actually, let me
ask that part first
so I don't throw too
many questions at once.
We do.
We used to do all of our
forecasting R actually.
And recently, Python
has stepped it up a bit.
And we've been doing
a lot more in Python.
Part of the reason for that is
that Stripe is somewhat more
Python based in
our infrastructure.
And so doing it in
Python allows us
to integrate with the
rest of Stripe systems
much more easily.
We do support R here.
We have R notebooks.
We have the ability
to schedule jobs in R.
But I'd say it's more like 20%
to 30% of data science usage.
And Python is a little bit more,
which R is close to my heart.
That's the programming
language that I started out
in grad school.
And I could live in
the tidyverse all day.
But we use it a
bit more for sort
of analytical, exploratory
analysis work, I would say,
and Python a bit more
for in production jobs.
In the follow-up
question, there was,
do you encourage and support
folks who want to learn one
while being more
proficient in the other?
Yeah, certainly.
I just had someone on my team
who was more proficient in R
but wanted to learn more Python.
And we sort of designed
a project for her
that allowed her to do that.
Awesome.
Another anonymous question from
earlier was, based on the fact
that there would be underlying
uncertainties in the forecast,
how do you make your
partner teams aware of
and consider those
uncertainties?
Yeah, a complex question.
We talk about it
a lot with them.
We show the backtesting results.
Those are usually helpful
as sort of quantitative--
maybe it doesn't
tell you everything.
But it tells you
something about when
we looked over the past year,
here's the amount of error
that we saw.
Here's how you might think
about that going forward.
There's a lot of fancier
joint uncertainty
throughout the
hierarchy methodologies
that we are exploring as well.
I think uncertainty is one
of the most useful concepts
for forecasting
within the business.
But it's very hard to propagate
the right level of uncertainty
throughout the hierarchy because
you introduce uncertainty
both at the modeling,
the initial modeling,
various points, and
in the reconciliation.
And so that's somewhat more
of an interesting problem
to get to uncertainty bands that
you're actually confident in.
So we do that.
We explore it from
the statistical side.
But we also from the
business side just sort
of take the
perspective of, here's
what we've seen historically.
You should expect some
uncertainty in the forecast.
And then really digging in
when we do see forecast misses.
Thank you.
I saw on LinkedIn, I think it
was a post maybe from a year
ago, where you're presenting on
managing a remote and globally
distributed data science
team and was curious
if you have any
tips that you'd like
to share with us in terms
of managing a team that's
all over.
Yeah.
And this was true
even pre-COVID.
So I have folks in Dublin,
Ireland, in New York, DC--
I'm in Minnesota--
folks in SF and Seattle.
I think that's it.
So we're very distributed,
have been for a while.
I talked a bit about the
early stage technical feedback
meetings.
That has actually been a
surprisingly useful thing
to do just for making sure that
we have that weekly touchpoint
with the team.
You can do Zoom happy hours
and those kinds of things.
And those are nice.
But it's nice to have a little
bit of structure and topic
to what we're trying to do and
to be able to have somewhat
of a technical conversation in
a very low-stakes environment.
We don't expect you to have a
polished presentation, but much
more of a rainstorm-type
atmosphere.
So having that touchpoint
has been really nice.
What else do we do?
Snacks.
People love snacks.
So I will-- there are a number
of services that you can send
snacks to people that just--
I think there's a
certain nice feeling
that people get by sharing
the same snacks on Zoom.
It's a good one.
I'm trying to remember what
are our other strategies.
I think just-- oh,
focusing on onboarding,
that's another big one.
When folks start
remotely, that's
a very different
experience than it
used to be where they were
in the office among everybody
in a starting class,
seeing everyone.
So I focus really
closely on new folks.
I meet with them every
day when they're starting.
I set up meetings with
the relevant people
that they need to meet.
I make sure they have the
resources that they need.
The first month or so, I
just focus really closely
on new folks and making sure
they get integrated because it
doesn't happen naturally.
In a remote world, you
really have to work at that.
Absolutely, I love the
point of even just sharing
the same snacks, something
little like that.
And Libby, I see you timed
your comment perfectly
to when Dara was actually
talking about onboarding too.
So just want to see if
you had any follow-up
question on that, Libby?
Yeah, that was really,
really well timed.
I asked, and then
Dara answered it.
Yeah.
I think onboarding is
a really tough thing
in data science in general,
and then extra tough
when everybody's remote, right?
And so I was kind of wondering
what emphasis you put on that
and how it worked, and
if you buddied people up
and things like that.
But you really hit
the nail on the head.
It has to be intentional.
It's not going to happen
spontaneously, right?
People aren't going
to just integrate
into a group and seamlessly
work with everybody.
There has to be some
intention there.
So that was good to hear.
If you have any expansion
on that, I'd love to hear.
But if not, you did a
great job answering.
Yeah, you hit
most of the points.
We do have spin-up buddies.
And so people get paired up
with an existing data scientist
or data analyst that they
can meet with and ask
any question to at any point.
There's a Stripe-wide
onboarding curriculum
that teaches people
about payments
and the Stripe product.
And then we have a data
science-specific curriculum
as well, how to set
up your environment,
how do we use Git at
Stripe, some of the more
technical classes that we run.
And those are both
pretty helpful.
But yeah, from there,
it is very much
just making sure to meet
with the right-- oh,
and we have a spin-up project.
So that's the other thing
that we do very intentionally.
We plan a sort of
well-scoped project
that we give to new folks
that should allow them
some room for exploration.
It should be important
to the business,
but not business critical,
need-it-next-week-type
of project so that they can
ship something that is important
but not feel that sort of
time pressure immediately.
They need to have some time
to spin up on our systems
and meet folks.
That's great.
Who comes up with that project?
The manager does.
OK.
And do the newly
onboarded people
work together on that and
share results with each other?
[INAUDIBLE] side they
do because there's enough
engineers.
On the data science side,
it's typically just sort
of one person per project.
So I know we're getting
to the end of our time here,
but one question I love to
ask people when we have time
is, what is the
best career advice
that you've ever received, or
maybe not best, but something
that sticks in your mind?
Something that
speaks to my mind
is to think about choosing the
wild card when you're presented
with multiple choices.
So for me, when I was
choosing my PhD advisor,
I had two rotations-- you
do three rotations, right?
I had two rotations
that I had planned ahead
of time that I knew I was very
interested in their research
that would go really
well, I thought.
And they did both
go really well.
And I really liked those labs.
And then the third one was
this brand-new professor.
I would be the
first grad student.
It was a little bit outside
the kind of research
that I had done before.
So I thought, I'll just
do this wildcard rotation.
And of course, that was the
lab that I ended up joining.
I was the first grad
student and ended up
having just this fantastic
experience with my advisor
and with the research.
And that also has held true
as I've made other career
decisions along the way--
choosing to go to Stripe
rather than stay in something
in biology, choosing
to go to data science
rather than do an
academic postdoc.
Sometimes that
wildcard choice can
feel a little scary, but
also kind of enticing.
And for me, it's
just trying to not
be afraid to choose that
option among choices
has worked out well.
Thank you.
That's great advice.
And Priyanka, I like
your comment in the chat,
too, when I asked that
question to also frame it as,
it could be advice
that you've been given
or that you have given
somebody else too.
I just wanted to
double check that I
haven't missed anybody's
questions in the chat
or on Slido.
So feel free to raise your hand
here or just unmute as well.
I'll give people a
few seconds here.
But, Dara, when you were talking
about some of the conversations
you have with your direct
reports on their career growth,
you mentioned some recommended
reading or resources
that you give them.
And I was curious
if that's something
you could share with
us, or if you have
any books that you'd recommend?
Sure.
At Stripe, there's often
manager workshops or trainings.
And so I'm constantly
in a state of learning
as well about things.
So I'll just share a couple
that are sort of top of mind.
There's lots of-- for books on
management and actually just
general career books,
one of my favorites is--
what's it called-- The Manager's
Path by Camille Fournier.
And she was the CTO
at Rent the Runway.
And so she takes you through how
you can think about your career
from as a manager from
managing an intern,
to managing a few
folks, managing a larger
team, all the way up, up,
up to being an executive.
I think that's very useful
both for seasoned managers
to understand how to think about
your career at various levels.
It's certainly one that I
revisit from time to time
as I've moved through my career.
So I find that one
to be super useful.
The High Output Management book
by Andy Grove is a classic.
It's one that we reference
a lot at Stripe as well.
These, again, are more
management focused,
but I think good resources for
thinking about your career.
One this framework
that I have been
using in career
conversations recently
is kind of interesting.
It's called the SCARF framework
it's a neurobiology thing.
And it's about how you respond
to stressful situations.
So it's like--
I'm not sure if I can remember
what they all are now.
But it's things
like, connectedness,
autonomy, relationships,
and thinking about what's
important to you in your work.
And so I use that and
ask people to talk
about what resonates with
them in the SCARF framework.
And it's funny how
different people really
value different things
when it comes to their work
and what's important to them.
And so I found that a
very helpful framework
for learning about folks
and for folks to self
identify what's
important to them.
Thank you.
I'm trying to find the link.
So it's Scarf--
S-C-A-R-F?
Uh-huh.
OK.
I like to share some
of the links as we go.
And the book that you
said by Andy Grove, what
was the name of that one?
High Output Management.
OK.
Awesome.
Thank you so much, Dara,
for joining us here.
If people do want to
get connected with you
or keep in touch, is
LinkedIn the best way?
Yes, that's a
great way to find me.
OK.
Awesome.
Thank you so much for sharing
your experience with us
and answering all
of our questions.
Thank you, everybody, for
the great questions as well.
Great to meet you all.
Have a great day, everybody.
Thank you so much.